il reste 30 secondes au décompte Siron
that go s'installe la caméra roule
ici et maintenant enriger les
intervenants sont prêts et cadrer le
journalisme russe indépendant à vos
exercices en exil il est plus pertinent
que jamais je suis absolument sûr que
c'est une
minorité agressive qui se sont la guerre
mais pour le moment il possède tous les
moyens pour diffuser l'information
cet extrait de la télévision d'État la
vérité les faits sont des concepts qui
ont complètement disparu du paysage
médiatique sous l'emprise du
kremliné
et c'est la censure de toute voix
opposée à la guerre qui avait forcé la
chaîne de télévision Dodge la seule
indépendance de Russie a quitté Moscou
au printemps
il aura fallu des mois et beaucoup
d'efforts pour relancer ses activités
depuis Riga
c'est grâce à YouTube encore disponible
en Russie et une licence de diffusion
fournie par la Lettonie que Dolls a
retrouvé sa voix
la journaliste Maria borzounova est
parmi les plus connus de la chaîne
apprécié pour son franc-parler elle se
consacre à temps plein à démasquer les
mensonges des autorités
et des témoignages concrets que Dolls
réussite tous les jours à capter
l'attention des Russes 14 millions de
téléspectateurs en Russie au mois de
septembre et le dis toi continue de
gonfler
Elena elle appelle le Rostov et
s'insurge du fait que sa petite fille de
7 ans a dû préparer des boîtes de vivres
pour les soldats au front comme activité
à l'école
je sais que nous pouvons faire plus que
14 millions et aussi je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de médias indépendants qui
travaillent maintenant en exil beaucoup
de jeunes comme olycia qui écrit pour le
site indépendant hola parce que c'est
encore possible pour une journaliste en
exil comme vous ruse d'être lu et
entendu en Russie
oui mais c'est difficile on les siens
refusent de baisser les bras et tous les
moyens sont bons pour sensibiliser son
peuple par exemple moi je
ne pas bloquer les gens avec la position
différente avec la position
problématique vous les écoutez
oui j'écoute aussi douloureux soit-il
que d'entendre les opinions de ses
compatriotes elle sent le vent tourner
il devient pelouse opposant plus
critique plus critique oui mais il faut
comprendre que les gens ont réussi
pendant plus que 20 ans ils sont été
sous cette
pression de la propagande il faut les
soigner il faut
il faut parler parler et parler parce
que les gens ils ont beaucoup de doutes
aujourd'hui le message du Kremlin c'est
que les forces ukrainiennes préparent
une bombe sale vous vous adaptez comment
pour dire aux Russes qu'il y a peut-être
une autre histoire derrière nous nous
comprenons qui a pas de preuve que le
ministère de la Défense les ministère
des Affaires étrangers ils disent
beaucoup de monde mais il y a pas de
preuve
chaque jour en Russie amène une nouvelle
épreuve avec une télévision d'État qui
est de plus en plus agressive voire même
criminelle selon lui je pense qu'il
devienne plus un plus
animaux il dit des choses qui sont
absolument impossible à écouter
notre rôle et de dire aux gens que si
quelqu'un est fou
ce n'est pas la normalité ils sont ils
sont fous dire encore une fois que tu es
n'est pas normal
vous le voulez garder leur sensibilité
si être russe à l'étranger vient avec
son lot de honte maintenir le dialogue
avec la maison et vitale
plus important que jamais
[Musique]